Herkese merhaba
ben Sinan
Sinan
kendimi bana anlatılanlara göre
Çocukluğum zamanında böyle tanıtmışım
İnsanlar neden sıkı yumruk diye
sordularını bitiremeden karınlarında da
bir yumruk atıp harekete geçermiş
esasında fırlama alalım hareketliliğim
ve
kendi etrafında Çocukluğumda yarattığım
Dünya
babamın
sporunun içerisinde yaptıklarının
içerisinde
kendi alanımı yaratma çabasıydı
belli noktalarda zaten bugün
halen Necati'nin oğlu olarak tanıdığım
tek yerdeyim tartayım
hikayemin
3 bölümü var
ikisinin bir kısmını tanıtılırken izleme
fırsatı yakaladık bu hikayenin
içerisinde en önemli etken babamın
basketbolcu oluşu
onun basketbol oynayışı sırasında her
bulduğumuz fırsatta abimle
salonun tozlu alanında
maçın aralarında iken sahanın içerisinde
basketbol oynarken bulduk
ve demin bahsettiğim hareketliliğim
demin bahsettiğim biraz fırlamalıyım
Aslında kontroller altına alabilmek için
biraz daha odaklandırabilmek için o 28'e
15'lik alan benim için biçilmiş kaftandı
kendi hayatımı
anlamlandırmaya başladığım ilk 20 sene
içerisinde ben o soğan içerisinde
öğrenebildiğim her şeyi öğrenmeye
başladım
Bir nevi sünger gibiydi
babamın kariyerini izledim versem yalan
olur çok hatırlamıyorum ama abim Murat
Can Benim için araba yarışı oyunlarında
ki Hayalet Araba gibiydi her zaman bir
adım önümde her zaman onun hatalarından
ve onun başarılarından beslenebileceğim
mesafedeydi
Ben tabii ki de hayatımın ikinci
sekmesinde bundan çok faydalandım
ama ilk ses etmesinde de
etrafımdaki imkanlar içerisinde babamdan
abimden ve Türk basketbolunda emek
vermiş herkesten belli şekillerde
faydalandım
geçmişe dönüp baktığımda en iyi yaptım
diyebileceğim şey
merakım ve başkalarının yaptıklarını
birazcık taklit edebilme yeteneğinde o
taktiklerle beraber Çocukluğumda
evimizde duvara asılı benim boyumdan
askısı olan potada Michael jordan'ın
smaçlarını taklit ederek
sahaya girdiğimde
Jason williams'ın paslarını taklit
ederek
biraz daha iş ciddiye binmeye
başladığında profesyonel olarak kendimi
kanıtlamam gerektiğini üniversitede
okuluma devam ederken basketbol
oynayabilmem için daha da ciddi
insanları ilham almaya başlamam
gerektiğini gördüm ve taklitlerimi
Aslında yeteneğe ve performansa nasıl
dönüştürebileceğini
Amerika serüveni esasında
Tarsus'ta hala geçerli olan ama kırmaya
çalıştığım bir kalıbın bir parçasıydı
Necati'nin oğlundan Sinan'a evlenmem
gerekiyordu
çok da kolay olmadı İlk uçağa bindiğimde
gerçekten korkuyordum
yolculuğun Her adımında da
neler olacağını bilmiyordum Sadık demin
biraz bahsetti Konfor alanının çok
dışına çıkmıştım
o süreç ilerledikçe basketbol sahası ve
basketbolun dış çizgileri benim için
büyülü bir alan olmaya kendimi
göstermeye kendimi kanıtlamaya fırsat
verdim
ve attığım Her Adım basketbollu içinde
bulundurduğundan dolayı o dağının
şaşmayacağı bir noktadaydı esasında
zaten benim Amerika'ya okumak için
gitmemdeki en büyük etken Basketbolu
kendi imkanlarımla
başkasına fazla fırsat vermeden
oynayabilmekti ve bunu
iyi kötü başardığını düşünüyorum
Türkiye'ye döndüğümde hayatımın ikinci
safhası başladı
bu sefer gerçekten abimin yaşadığı
profesyonel Hayatın benim jenerasyonu
nasıl yansıdığını oradaki öğrenimlerinle
beraber
gerçekten sinanı tanımış bir halde
Türkiye'ye döndüğümde Türkiye'ye tanıtma
fırsatını yakaladım
16 sene profesyonel Basketbol oynadım
bunun
her seferinde de türkiye’de
bununla beraber
Türkiye'yi Avrupa'da temsil eden kupa
Avrupa'da temsil eden kulüplerle
oynamanın yanında milli forma giyme
şansı yakaladım
gerçekten Sinan Güler'i forma ile
birlikte kim olduğunu tanıtabildiğimi
düşünüyorum ve bu yolda da
başta Abim ve babam olmak üzere onların
desteğini her zaman görmüş olmak
ailemin arkadaşlarımın benim büyüyüşü
benim yükselişimi benim merdivenleri
beşer beşer çıkışımı takip ediyor olması
çok mutluluk ve heyecan vericiydi
yaklaşık 2 gün önce
Euro Cup
şampiyonluğunun 7 senesi kutlandı
Aslında çok büyük bir kutlama esasında
sosyal medya üzerinden kendinizce
paylaşımlar yaptık Ama
dışarıda basketbol takımındaki
arkadaşlarla konuşurken söylüyordum
yaşadığımız her gün kazanmak için
kaybetmek için
ilerlediğimiz süreç içerisinde esasında
o gün çok önemli
bugün geriye dönüp baktığımda
2016'daki şampiyonu hakkında bir sürü
hikaye anlatabilirim hatırladığım bir
sürü an var iyisiyle kötüsüyle sezon
içerisinde zor geçen anlarla birlikte
ama özünde
benliğimle beraber hatırlıyor muyum
açıkçası Hayır
bu hikayeyi çizmeye başladığım her
noktada da
iyisini ve kötüsünü
yaşadıklarımla öğrendiklerimle karşıma
çıkan engellerle nasıl başa
çıkabileceğini öğrendiğim bir süreç oldu
basketbol esasında hareketin çok olduğu
ama hareketin içerisinde odağın çok
önemli olduğu bir spor
ve Bunun içerisinde o daha bulduğun anda
takım olarak da bu odakta bir kolektif
bir paylaşımcı bir ortam yakaladığın
anda başarılı olmammak kaçınılmaz
2016 senesinde Galatasaray ile
yaşadığımız 2010 senesinde Türkiye milli
takımı ile yaşadığımız süreçler bunu çok
net bir şekilde gösteriyordu
başta bahsettim Hareketli bir sporcuydu
çocuktum fırlamadım
sahanın getirdiği imkanlarla ve sahanı
bana verdiği kurallarla onu biraz
yontması fırsatı yakaladım
ikinci evrende oyuncu olarak kendimi
kanıtlamaya ve
kendi hikayemi üzerinde forma varken
nasıl anlatabildiğimi görmeye başladım
basketbolculuk takım olarak yapıldığında
etrafında farklı İnsanların olduğu
taraftarlarla beraber çok daha ihtişamlı
ve güzel olan bir ortam
ama aynı zamanda çok da zor
fazlasıyla özverinin gerektiği
kendini geliştirmek için
yanındaki takım arkadaşında durmadan
rekabet ettiği
her gün kazanmak için oynayacağın ama
bazı günler kaybedeceğim bir oyun
esasında sonsuz oyun yaşadığımız bu
hayatın içerisinde çok sonu olan
ve sonunun çoğu zaman senin kontrolünde
olmadığı bir alan
Bunu öğrenmek 40 senemi aldı
ve geçmişe dönüp baktığımda
neleri daha iyi yapabilirdim neleri
farklı yapabilirdim diyeceğim anları
esasında oynadığım maçlardan daha fazla
hatırlıyorum
hayatım boyunca ailemin desteğini
arkamda gördüğüm ortamda kendimi tanıtma
hırsıyla yeri geldiği zaman abimle
babamla hınca hınç bir rekabete kendi
içimde girdiğim anda
sahaya çıktığımda bir sürü şeyi
unutabiliyordum
basketbol oynamaya başlıyordum
oyunun bir parçasıydım
bunları anlatırken
esasında konuşmam biraz kendiliğinden
gelişiyor Çünkü Haziran ayı itibariyle
geçtiğimiz Haziran ayı itibariyle artık
ben formayı çıkardım
ve gerçekten yine
Sinan'ın kim olduğunu
Sinan'ın nasıl bir etki yaratacağını
ailesinden
dostlarından
Kendinden daha küçük gençlerden ve
esasında dünyada bana ilham veren
kişilerden nasıl etkileneceğini gördüğüm
bir periyottan geçiyorum
çok da kolay değil 40 sene boyunca
kendime basketbolla tanımlamış
basketbolda tanımlamak istemiş Bir birey
olarak şu an hayatın dışında sonucu
olmayan bir oyunun bir parçası olup
kendi yolunu çizerken yaptıklarından
nasıl beslendiğini gösteren bir dünya
yaratmaya çalışıyorum
bununla beraber
bir aile büyütmeye çalışırken
üç buçuk yaşında bir kızımız var onun
kendi yaşayacağı hayatın içerisinde
nasıl bir rol alacağımı öğrenmeye
çabalıyorum
bütün bu sürecin içerisinde önemli
gördüğüm şey
bolluk her zaman etrafımızda olan bir
şey
sporda bugün başarıyı ön planı olan
çıkar ön plana çıkar sevinmiş olan
bireyler veya takımlarda hep
ufak tefek yokluklardan büyüyen
takımları görebiliyoruz
sporda da en üst seviyeye çıkan İnsanlar
genellikle en başladığı nokta
kendi tırnaklarıyla kazıkları yerler
olabiliyor
bolluğun içerisinde de
esasında hareket alanını belirleyen şey
de kendi odağımız oluyor
Bugün
hayatımın iki evresinde biriktirdiğim
her şeyle birlikte
elimde gerçekten bol miktarda olan
fırsatlar var
bu fırsatların yanında aynı zamanda
kendince dünyayı kendi dünyamı kendi
etrafındaki dünyayı
Örnek vermek gerekirse Türkiye'deki spor
kültürünü değiştirmeye inandığım alanlar
var
ama bunların hiçbirine
odağımın
net olmadığı şekilde müdahale etmeye
çalıştığımda başarılı olamayacağımı
geçmişte yaptıklarımla beraber görüyorum
benim hayatımda Odak noktası önce babam
gibi bir basketbolcu olmaktı
sonra abim gibi bir basketbolcu olmaktı
Tabii arada Michael jordanlar Onlar
Bunlar giriyorlar hayatın içerisinde ama
kendimi tanırken ki yolda hep önümde
kolay ulaşabileceğim bir kol mesafemde
olan yeri geldiğinde sarılabileceğim
hedeflerim vardı
Şimdi de beraber yarattığımız o dünya
içerisinde bu hikayeyi
sporu etkiyi katılımcılığı kullanarak
nereye getirebileceğimizi düşünüyoruz
Ben olabildiğince
yapabildiğim her şeyin içerisinde
bunları düşünerek hareket etmeye
çabalıyorum
çok heyecanlı bir dönem var önümde diye
düşünüyorum
Dün tekrardan böyle yazmaya çalışırken
hesapladım bugüne kadar bugün itibariyle
14.416 gündür hayattayım
bunun 13 bini basketbolda geçti
muhtemelen
'e yakın günü sahanın dışında
geçiriyorum ki son 300 günü falan
geçtiğimiz dönemlerdir
ve önümde de bir bu kadar daha günü
olduğuna inanmak istiyorum Hatta belki
de Daha da fazlası ve Türk sporuna
yaptığım etkileri gördüğümde gerçekten
Neler yapabileceğimi de odaklandığım
noktada
etrafımdaki doğru insanların doğru
yaptıklarından beslendiğim noktada
çok heyecanlı bir alan Görüyorum orada
ve bunu tek başıma yapamayacağımı yeni
yeni keşfediyorum basketbol oynarken her
şey çok kolaymış Çünkü yanında takım
arkadaşlarım vardı Ve benim yapamadığım
birini yaptığını Onu yapamadığında benim
yapabildiğimi biliyordum
bugün
girişimcilikle
inovasyonla
kültürü değiştirebileceğimiz noktalarda
ben tek başıma ancak Don Kişot'un yel
değirmenlerinin karşısında durduğu gibi
durabilirim
ama hepimizin
birlikte atacağı adımlarla
paylaşımcı şeffaf diyaloglu
Etrafındaki insanları daha iyi yapmaya
daha katılımcı yapmaya motive eden
şekilde yaptığımız sürece
birey olarak ben kendi hedeflerime
ulaşabilirim Ve eminim ki sizlerin kendi
hedefleri varsa Sizlerde ulaşabilirsiniz
2 gerçekten zor zamanlardan geçtiğimiz
bir dönemin içerisinde
ülkemizin belirli kültürel
imkanlarını değiştirebiliriz Aynı
zamanda da dünyayı değiştirebilecek
fırsatları buluruz
burada önemli olan şey bolluğun
içerisinde
hem temsil ettiğimiz değerlerin ne
olduğunu bilmek hem
atacağımız adımları
iyilik için paylaşımcılık için ve
kendimizin iyiliğini düşünürken aynı
zamanda yanımızın yanımızdakileri nasıl
daha yaparız diye düşünmek
ve aynı zamanda da her zaman için
meraklı olarak kendimizi geliştirmeye
açık olmak gerektiğini düşünüyorum
teşekkürler
[Alkış]